okay just a little video showing off the
tractor kind of a little bit about it a
little bit of a walk around and one
thing I kind of pointed out we uh
that we were gonna do and actually just
did it but I the intro that I made uh
before we did it didn't work out so I'm
just redoing it right now
but with the bucket the idea was we've
got the step hitch receiver we're gonna
put on it
uh
took it down to the neighbors he welded
it on I've got some video we're about to
see of it and then we'll see the close
of the video
[Music]
all right so we just got back
doing a little welding
and uh
like I said it's just a little uh
step bumper receiver 25 bucks at Harbor
Freight something like that they're
pretty cheap I mean these things are you
pick these up on eBay actually made for
the tractor
uh quite a bit more expensive but uh
buddy of mine you know is doing some
welding
got it mounted right on front of the
tractor here
I can use it for moving trailers around
also uh you can buy you know hooks and
some other
uh little little attachments that slide
in those hitches I know they sell hooks
they sell
stuff like that where you can hook a
chain up to it and then with the chain
uh you kind of use it to pick stuff up
I'm probably gonna Mount some hooks on
the side of it too I got a couple other
plans for this tractor
but anyway hope you liked the video
if you
if you liked it please subscribe
give a like
maybe leave a comment it's all
appreciated
again it's Matt the moment Hunter from
McGee farms